Video games are great fun, except for those
occasional moments when they totally stink.
Is there anything worse than playing an awesome
game only to have it totally derailed by a
single moment of pure idiocy?
Here's a look at some video games almost ruined
by one cutscene.
Sonic the Hedgehog
One of the biggest facepalms in videogame
history took place in 2006's Sonic the Hedgehog,
thanks to the infamous kiss between Princess
Elise and Sonic taking center stage at the
Cringe Olympics.
Nonsensical plot developments are usually
fine, especially in a fun platformer like
this, quotation marks on the "fun," but this
weird fanfic romance between a human and a
hedgehog was just a little bizarre.
Super Mario Bros. 2
There's no denying Super Mario Bros. 2 is
an insanely fun classic.
The many different worlds and enemies in this
title gave it loads of character, and players
can have a great time digging up sand, throwing
eggs back at Birdo, and piloting supporting
characters like Toad and Princess Peach.
But then you get to the end and, well, this
happens.
Yes, it was all a dream.
Congratulations, you just completely wasted
your time!
Saints Row the Third
Considering you can fire octopi onto people's
heads to make them dance, the silly and slapsticky
Saints Row the Third seems like just a goofy,
over the top joyride.
And usually it is.
That's why it's so jarring when beloved character
Johnny Gat abruptly gets offed during a mission.
"Johnny, we're about to jump!"
"Hang on, I'll see you at ---"
Talk about a total mood killer!
Bayonetta
There's fanservice, and there's just weird
ickiness.
That lined wasn't blurred so much as obliterated
at the end of the action classic Bayonetta,
where victorious gamers are treated to a three
minute dance number called "Let's Dance Boys"
featuring the titular heroine just... flouncing
around for your enjoyment.
Don't worry, it's totally natural to feel
ashamed after playing this game.
Kingdom Hearts 2
At least the dance sequence in Kingdom Hearts
2 has one thing going for it: there's no sign
of Bayonetta.
But that's the only good thing we can say
about the horrible "Swim This Way" musical
number that features Sora dancing with the
cast of The Little Mermaid.
No.
Just… no.
The Legend of Zelda: Skyward Sword
There's a lot to love in the classic Zelda
game Skyward Sword…but there's also Groose.
For whatever reason, this caricature of a
bully from an '80s shows up and chases down
Link after descending from Skyloft.
Then players have to sit through several minutes
of Groose grunting and hooting about himself,
his new world, and all sorts of other annoying
crap.
Just let us get on with saving Zelda already!
Star Ocean 4
Get ready to scratch your noggin in confusion
at one of the most awkward cutscenes of all
time, courtesy of Star Ocean 4's "Private
Action" system.
These are cutscenes you can trigger to raise
your affection level with specific party members.
That's fine, but the creepily childlike Lymle,
who is actually 15 years old, gets a little
too affectionate.
Even the other characters in the game are
visibly uncomfortable with how creepy she
is, and send her off to her own room instead.
Yikes.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!